有为什么学的很多人用不出来啊
就很努力啊
但是生活一团糟
是学习这个东西没用的
我这么跟大家讲吧
我99%赚钱的机能都是通过学习货的
那这个差距是在哪了
我发现很多人学习的渡量单位错了
记住啊
有一个人成长
是否成长了
它的渡量单位不是你学会的渡少知识
不是你知道的渡少知识
而是你丢负了多少个完整的产品
并获得市场的大会
我再说一遍啊
一个人成长的红量标准
不是你学会的渡
知识不是你懂得多少东西
而是你丢负了多少个完整的产品
并从市场中获得分会
说一个稍微不太好理解的例子吧
就是如果你会投资的话
你不会投资就你就不一个支持吧
对吧
我们要评价一家公司是不是好公司
只不得投
要看它的周酸率
什么意思呢
就是你买了一些原材料
对吧比如说你开饭店的
你买了一堆菜也见了
然后这个菜
快速的作弯成品
作弯饭
作弯菜
什么时候再进亲的互存
然后再把它作弯成品
来你看你是一天
还是一臭还是一年对吧
各位你去思考一下
如果一家饭店
见了一堆菜
一年都没消化出去
哇它的周酸率
可能是一年
那你这家饭店不倒闭都完了
所以各位好好想象一下
为什么我们很多人
学了很多东西
没有成果
你这个周酸率可能不是一年
对不对
所以我给大家讲
为什么一定要是丢富的
一定是丢富的
完全的产品并且获得
是上个放会
你像我原来开公司
我招人和很多人招人不太样
很多人招人说
你现在在大学毕业的
你过去修什么东西
对吧
你获得什么讲
正书
各位我不是的
我基本上就是看你
过去完成过那些产品
对吧
最绅的办法
比如说你生愿来告诉我
给他不上
你有云餐用的那些像
那这个像不是你的
对吧
这个你做一个成愿
你不要告诉我
你不要给他他不吃吗
对不对
你没有那一番
反正还没你告诉我
这个是最绅的
就是你完成了哪些
完整的产品
并且获得到实际上的办法
就是最绅的条件
为什么要这么做
要跟大家讲
第一件事情
就是物理成绩
就什么叫物理成绩呢
我跟大家讲
想法很简单
想吗
谁还不会想
谁都会想
但是想认语
做很难
再好的想法
你不打他作用产品
结果是认语
所以
当你做一个产品的时候
这个产品你会遇到
一百个困难
你就是要解军
那一百个困难
获得成长
但是很多人就退错了呀
对不对
因为你只有在做的
共产品的发现问题
你发现问责以后
你去解决它
你才成长了
但是很多人卡在这了
对吧
这是我们说的第一个
第二个的话
就是我们说秘广
就是你获得一个秘广的哪里
这位你把一个事做成
我一讲
你做成到百分之
八十这个事挺容易的
你完成算了百分之二
从百分之八十到百分之百分之九
我就告诉你
你的那个实惊的成本
是完成百分之八十的几倍
是百万百分之百分之百分之百分之百分之百分之百分之百分之百
那你中间你说干嘛
你说很多很多的细节
对吧
比如说你要完成一个产品的话
首先第一个
你要有有些能够解决的排续
然后我们现在很难到
现在被这个都不知道
有些能够解决的排续
你要懂得取数
懂得取数
你看
我朋友好多人为什么现在生活过的一盆糟了
每天忙的
这个叫叫叫叫叫叫叫票票第二个
但是就是你不知道怎么去取数
对吧
你要懂得取数
同时你要能够深入细节
你就细节出来以后
你要去深入细节
你要有一个整体的
整体的判断
什么叫整体的判断
对吧
比如说你作用产品
你需要除了做产品之外
你要考虑实际上的
你需要你要考虑细节跳
对吧
你要考虑是安全的问题
就很多是在避免底的东西
对吧
所以有并化的能力的人
和没有并化的能力的人
对问题的知识的
完整度深度的理解
是完全不一样
所以第二个是背缓的同意
第三个是什么
就是市场严证的能力
就是你要从市场中活得反会
你自己做的无理想
这个东西很好的
对吧
但是你在这条推向市场的时候
我反而不跟大家讲
我们理解的世界和真实世界
一定会有平常
就我们大多人从学校出来以后
自身就不空间了
而学校的知识
真实世界是不一样的
对吧
而且就算你更新我告诉你
这个世界每天都在变化
你要用昨天的经验去
完成进展是你大战理
也会是吧
我们的这个真实世界是有偏差的
然后你认为这个东西好不醒的
你争到市场中
然后这个市场会会给你反会的
对吧
我就拿这个拍照的视频来说
就好多人就跟我说
我又不放量的
我又用户
对吧
但是为什么不赚钱
我给大家解释一些事情
就是你的视频有播放量
说明你切中了用户的痛点
用户的需求
但是呢
如果你的储碗的发量比较高
说明有一家了
说明有社交价值了
有人为你付费什么什么
说明你真的提供几个发达
没有几个发达
没有费用的
能听到我意思吧
所以你要去市场严重
我记得过得刚老是说了
就话特别有道理
它是对立刻
这个叫什么
就公式向上夫妇俩
去办事不是
我不是
修立高高
搞不好
对吧
公式向上
过得刚老是说
就很有意思
我发说
剪也一个向上严
最好的标准是什么
就是你公开
公开
在他有多少人
看来听你的向上
只是最基本的标准
对吧
所以给你们看
这就是我们
为什么一定要交付一个
完整的产品
并获得是一样的
否则的话
你的那个知识都是酷存
就是我跟你家想
那是
你开个饭店
太新的一大堆
成品没人买了
对吧
那为什么很重要
还卡的这个位置
是主要是有两点
第一点就是投了成品不太一样
我刚才说了
就完成了
不是80%很容易的
完成了
是80%很容易的
但是完成20%
20%
是不是在80%到90%
90%
好
那个是80%
到10%的好几位
但是呢
就和那个冰山一样
你完成那个
80%的工作量
外面能看到
然后你首先那都是细节
确实问题
确实是卡点
确实那些东西
其实你不显攻的样子
对吧
但是那个东西
我跟你讲
要支付很多很多的时间
你要去完成
很多很多
你就不愿意去完成了
就他们觉得我把这个关系
他们听完成了
细节我就不愿意好了
对吧
这就可能别人做个事情
但是我告诉你
什么叫糊塵口
真正的糊塵
恰恰是
并许人想办了这个
细节
在听我一样
这叫护塵核
然后还有一个原因
什么呢
那就这个面子
我就这中国人就是扭面子
他一个个人是平衡
我那家朋友看
怎么办
我那家看
怎么看
怎么办
我那家不够丢人吗
就是我们好多人
他还在乎这个面子
就他有时候也知道
自己的东西拿出手
但是他觉得
反正我本哪儿出去
别人就不知道
对吧
对
我不行
我这个心手
来吧
我把包路了
是不是就好
他人就是
我记得我记得是盲格说吧
说你不要欺骗自己
你自己是虽容易欺骗
被你自己欺骗的
但是我们好人就喜欢欺骗自己
就是我不行
我知道行
你们不能不能
我知道
我只是并这个东西
但这啊
兄弟们
所以这个时候
跟大家讲什么办
就是如果你真的要承认
你必须突破这一关
你不突破这一关
你会发现你永远
我再说一边
就永远是那种
饭店里进了一批货
对吧
你竟然烂掉了
你不卖地卖出去
对吧
所以各位
到底还怎么做呢
首先我跟大家讲
你要做的第一件事情
就是要切换自己的思路
你比如说我需要
切换什么思路
就是要把自己从一个消费
把他变成一个
一个创作者
我跟他说我们年会啊
我们年会的时候
我的
我要修我们的组织说
我们年会都是组织自己
自打组织的
但是我跟他组织说
不要去做任何用户体验的事
就是搞年会的时候
用户体验的是
谁也不是居高
遇到问题
来的人刺激下去
把自己去想办法
为什么
我先讲一个事吧
就是上次我们在搞年会的时候
我要求大家接二天出项目
出项目是什么呢
就是晚上可能要
要用单级
我们要把东西打出来
对吧
他们那时候要去做大胆
你我说为什么要做大胆级
他们说不晚上了
你要把这种政策来需要一个胆级
好多人就是外地来的
他们不知道有什么男人都不要吧
他们有想要的
所以我们就想办法去
如果一个打印机都把它
能就能把它靠住
对不起
它就不要创业
对吧
那么我们在书的消费的时候
创造者这里面有很多问题
就是它是主动的消费者
什么概念
遇到一个问题以后
它的想法是
好
主办法是谁
问题但有哪些
那些爸爸问题
它会是特贸病的
但是创造者是什么概念
是
这是一个问题
这个问题
我怎么解决
我怎么能把它做得很好
对吧
所以我们故意这样做
就是让所有人
我们的老火
就必须把思路给我切换过来
从消费者变成创作者
记住
消费者是享受
创造者是创造者的
创造者的价值
我反而服务
什么时候能获得起
当你能被别人提供价的时候
别人就会给你提供价关呀
你包括你教我们年会的时候
我们有要求什么要求啊
就不是上去讲
我话话话话话话话话
讲三天干嘛呢
不是这样的
就是给一个想法
怕处
三十分钟
有想法
马上过处产品
然后只要去选中间中
对吧
三十分钟
然后你三十分钟为单位
为什么
我就是要让你
很两个标准
不是你今天来学的多少东西
而是你在
而是你发布了
多少个完整的产品
丁获得
是上反费
所以各位
这是思路上的
这款一定是要从一个
消费者
变成一个创作者
这个思路
不变
各位你是很难
对吧
很难获得成长的
还有一个具体操作
具体操作的话
干嘛呢
各位首先
你第一个你要
要有内中勇气
就是发布一个能实现功能的
但并不能把每个勇气
第二个
你必须把
完成的那种值行内拉
就值行内是非常非常重要的
第三个
你要有一个去市场中
获得反费的开放的心态
三条
所以第一个
就是你要有这个
就是
我不用那么还没
但是我先
满头用过的续续续
同时我的
执行内要一定要跟着
什么要去完成一个
完整的产品
然后的话呢
吃到这儿我再说一句
大家自己听见
想到男生
如果你做事情
总是做到
60%到80%
说明你只听不过
我做到60%
80%不变做
现在被他去了
说明你执行内部
做到90%多了
但是还是不发布
说明你完没主义
这个都是要去切换的
然后
我的身份会再挑战
那么我们普通人到底该怎么做呢
我的建议是这样的
你去看这个事情
就是
三部第一部是技能
就是我掌握了一个技能
我可以干什么事
对吧
比如说我会拍视频
第二个
你要有一个作品
什么有作品
就是你要
这个东西要把它变成一个作品
有没有市场反归
不重要
现在就是
市场反归
怎么样不重要
不是没有
有市场反归
不知道
市场反归
怎么样不要重要
我拍出一个
一定要视频来
我现在出一片文章来
做成一个产品出来
对吧
这个叫作品
从技能
一定要把它变成作品
我们很多人卡的
卡的那个
记得上了
作品已经是我自己的作品
这三个是绝对方
什么绝对方
就是我解决到
谁在什么样
请问她的问题
有人买蛋
这个叫绝对方
所以你要不在那块儿的成果
出去
然后再去
赶快
该亲
好吧
所以各位
我们最后总结也来吧
各位好
好 四个好一下
这种为什么我很能学习
然后我们也很努力
对吧
但是收货不了结果
就是因为学习没有
其实不是的
很良一个人成长的标准
不是你许了多少
注意单位啊
不是你个多少
而是什么呢
而是你
完成了
交付了多少个
完整的产品
并在市场中
获得了多少个人